the arizona cardinals as we know had a
one big new part in deandre hopkins who
has been paid there
and they are now two-and-oh and the
general managers put this stellar team
together
in arizona is back here on the rich
eisen show steve kahn how are you steve
rich i'm doing fantastic damn straight
congrats uh on the move to nbc that's
awesome thanks pal really appreciate
that
uh i'd like to give you your two cents
on the subject of
no preseason and whether you think that
we can draw
a line between that and some rash of
injuries or for some teams struggling
to start the season while other teams
like yours clearly aren't what do you
think steve
well that's a great question uh in our
case i think you know there are some
parallels with
execution and penalties in fact
unfortunately we lead the national
football league in penalties which is
uh a little concerning but uh
something i know we can clean up i know
cliff is certainly motivated to do that
and we know that they're fixable things
but
the injury part of it you know to me if
if you're going to put your finger on an
injury
uh because of the preseason i would have
thought there would have been more soft
tissue injuries uh
not things that are either ligament
damaged or structural
and it sounds like uh just from the
reports it sounds like
you know the amount of acls that were
incurred yesterday is
is probably an all-time high and when
you hear what your colleagues
in san francisco are saying right now
about the turf and met life and you know
you're going there
in week five to take on the jets and
then in week 14 against the giants what
do you do
as a general manager of the arizona
cardinals steve well it is it's
concerning and
and i think the one thing that we need
to do is certainly make sure that we're
wearing the appropriate
footwear i mean sometimes the length of
the spikes
um you know may have something to do
with it but we just need to make sure
that we're taking the
proper precautions and uh that we have
enough education
heading into that stadium we played
there last year and we didn't have any
issues
okay yeah because they replaced the turf
there and you know uh
the steelers apparently didn't say much
about it uh nor did the giants but
man that was something watching that
yesterday but i'm just again i'm just
trying to get in the mind of a general
manager of team that's 2-0 right now and
what what do you think when you're when
when you're sitting here
uh in week three getting ready for
detroit to come into your house a team
that you know
played you to a draw in week one last
year in that very building
well i mean you know it's it's a
week-to-week league and and we're just
watching detroit the first uh
two games of their season uh i think
they gave up leads in both games and
uh obviously when you're playing a uh a
team that has matthew stafford as the
quarterback they have
um some talent as well and and any given
sunday you can lose so
we have to uh clean up our mistakes we
have to minimize penalties
and we have to get back to to to play
mistake-free football for us to have
success success moving forward
steve kaim here on the rich eisen show
what was the first time uh
you realized deandre hopkins could be
had for you to take
in a trade when was the first time that
happened well it was a conversation
between bill o'brien and myself and i
i've known bill
back to the early 2000s when he was an
assistant coach at georgia tech
so we had a good relationship and and
just through uh you know usual dialogue
that we have with general managers and
head coaches um we just sort of brushed
upon the subject and
the fact that i felt like he was
available and david johnson was a guy
that certainly bill coveted
uh it all worked out for both of us and
we're certainly happy to have hop
was that last year when that first
happened trade deadline
yep that was last uh right before free
agency of last year
okay all right and then um did you hang
up the phone and you thought oh my god
this
this could actually happen well it was
it was unusual times because it was uh
ready to start a covet it was
hard for us to to get the players
physicals and as you know
no trade can be made until uh they were
all i should say made pending
uh players physical so i got a little
antsy and
and a little nervous when when we
couldn't get the physicals right away
but it all worked out we were able to
extend hop
as well a few weeks ago and uh really
glad we did to make sure we have him
under contract for the next five years
especially with the way he started i
mean i think he set an nfl record
with 22 receptions uh for you know a guy
that's
playing for a team for the first time
yeah i know so there
there you have it i mean some some guys
is it just like some guys you don't need
pre-season to fit in i mean is that is
that
that's again i guess to come full circle
here because there's going to be so much
conversation based on the fact that
there is no preseason you're already
hearing
uh i don't know if you heard if you were
on hold you know doug peterson in
philadelphia saying two and a half weeks
is not enough time
and um and so but you know
you don't seem to be having that problem
well again i
you know i think the the fact that we're
in year two of cliff kingsbury's offense
and then there's always a number of guys
that are just tremendous athletes
whether it's kyla murray
uh larry fitzgerald uh patrick peterson
uh deandre hopkins is certainly one of
them that you just roll the ball out
there and
they're generally better than any other
people in the field so
that certainly helps but uh you know pop
is a guy that came in
he already you know instantly brought a
tremendous amount of swag into our
locker room and
and confidence you know he plays
physical uh
he's a great route runner and him and
kyler were able to throw this summer so
they so they built some sort of a
uh you know relationship uh as well so
i think the comfort level was there from
the beginning all right steve you and i
have known each other for quite some
time
so um you know i'm gonna give you this
opportunity i don't know if you're going
to take it
i don't i'm okay this is my setup i
don't know if you're going to take it
but to those in uh the football world
who talk about stuff for a living and
analyze things and opinionate for a
living
um what would you say to those people
who maybe say had you on their show
right after the draft that you traded
josh rosen to miami
and right after you hired a coach who
had never been a head coach before
and went ahead and sent away josh rosen
after drafting kyler murray first
overall
and people wondering whether you knew
what the hell you were doing what do you
say to those people and i'm
kind of raising my hand right now steve
i don't i don't know if you're a
football spiker professionally
um but what do you what do you say to
those people steve kahn right now
i think it's fair question i mean i
think that um you know the media has to
do their job as well and
and i certainly respect that you know we
were coming off a stretch of
a couple years of football that uh that
i'm not very proud of you know prior to
that we went over 50 games in five years
when
we hired bruce arians as our head coach
and i took over as a general manager but
you know you can't live on the past and
as bruce always told me he was a dear
friend of mine
the elevator ride from the out of the
penthouse to the outhouse is a quick one
and it certainly was for a moment there
but um
you know i think in this business rich
you have to put on blinders and you have
to to believe in what you see and you
have to trust your instincts
and in those situations moving on from
josh which was tough
uh and drafting kyler and hiring cliff
kingsbury
um was was something that i felt
strongly about and uh hopefully we can
continue to reap the benefits
and you know i guess i guess instead of
spiking the football you kind of just
handed the ball back to the ref right
there knowing that there's more downs to
be played i guess steve
um but and when in this business also
uh we use phrases for guys who are
particularly tough
uh a problem and um kyler appears to be
a problem for defenses in a manner
that few quarterbacks can is this what
you envisioned
when you drafted him first overall what
we're seeing right now
yeah because you know and again uh to to
be honest with the process
i really did not want to like kyler as a
player because we had just drafted josh
the previous season
and i like josh rosen i thought he had a
lot of upside right
but um going into that pick which
when you have the first pick in the nfl
draft again to me you had to be honest
with the process
and what i saw on tape at oklahoma was a
guy who
ran the football and threw the football
like nobody had ever seen and when i say
that
i've seen guys who can run like him i've
seen guys who can throw like him but
i've never seen
the dual threat that he can pose and his
ability to create
with his feet is exceptional we all know
that but his ability to throw from the
pocket with accuracy and touch
is also from something i think is
exceptional he's amazing man
i i got to tell you he is amazing and
what he's been able to do in two weeks
is nothing short of amazing he's my i
he's must-see television
he's so much damn fun to watch i'm and i
have him in fantasy
what's it like to have him in real steve
i mean you know it really is you know i
think one of my kids said this it's like
watching a video game i mean he really
is it's
you know heats up angles with his foot
speed he drops back he throws lasers all
over the field
he's competitive as hell and he's just
scratching the surface too rich it's
amazing because
he just continues to get better and
better and as he learns to continue to
use his progression read defenses better
and get more acclimated to the
to the nfl game i just think the sky's
the limit for him well
after after the season was over uh last
year um
and this is before you got that you
connected with bill o'brien about
deandre hopkins i said that
uh kyler was going to come in uh and be
an mvp candidate top three in votes in
2020 i i
you know the offensive rookie of the
year award was well deserved and we're
seeing right now
and then this is when i realized i knew
that this was going to happen after
and it's not the deandre hopkins trade
it was the way your coach drafted it was
the way your coach drafted
his draft setup was like a james bond
lair uh or or like a cologne
ad um
i mean we're showing it right here on
the screen steve this is next level
stuff man
this is next level stuff you know
yeah what are you really what did you
think what did you think
i mean i just felt at that point we
didn't even have to make a pick at that
i just felt like we won the draft
last second
it was a lock right there i mean it was
an absolute lock
um and i imagine is there any part of
that screen
that resembles your draft setup from
that no
but the coolest thing about my draft
setup is and you've known this for years
is you are the backdrop
of my draft boards
and that is remain that way rich as long
as i'm general manager
well then i'm particularly happy about
your 2-0 start and not just because i
know you personally and uh that's pr
that's that's great
phenomenal so there's nothing at all
like you know you didn't draft in
loafers no socks
there's nothing there's no fire pit
there's no fire pit
no no you know the funny thing about
that uh about that pictures
is it would set up as you say for for a
cologne ad or whatever it may be
people don't realize i mean it makes
cliff kingsbury look like the ultimate
playboy
when in reality yes he's almost like a
grandpa i mean this guy gets in here at
3 30 in the morning
he goes home late at night i don't know
when he sleeps
and he is an absolute grinder so
i don't know when he gets to use that
house i certainly hope he does
but i haven't seen it well i told him uh
when he came on about his draft setup
um that that that the you know you're
hearing the hashtag
in seattle of let russ cook and you've
got your hands full obviously in your
division your hashtag for arizona should
be the fire pits lit
that's it 2020 cardinals hashtag fire
pits lit
i love it that's it man i'm i'm just
trying to let's just set it all up for
you steve
you know we appreciate it rich you got
it brother thanks for the call
thank you thank you so much thank you
we'll chat soon that's steve khan
general manager of the
arizona corners hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here